september is world alzheimer's awareness
month
and it seems we all know someone whose
family has been touched by the disease
yeah it impacts the whole family too
women are especially more susceptible to
alzheimer's
sherry's here now with news of a special
clinic it's right here in las vegas
and it's designed to help women avoid
the disease good morning sherry good
morning
alex you and i have a much greater
chance of having alzheimer's disease
than either john or nate
because women outnumber men three to one
with alzheimer's and researchers still
don't completely know why
there is no cure for alzheimer's but
there is evidence that the brain disease
could be delayed
or possibly even prevented with certain
changes
in our lifestyles like everybody at age
63
you do forget a few things here and
there but debbie morton of park city
utah
knows she could eventually lose her
memory and more
just like her father who lived with
alzheimer's disease for 12 years
by the time he died at age 87
it was actually more
i mean he was he had no words and he
could just eat
and walk that strong genetic risk moved
morton to sign up for the new women's
alzheimer's prevention center at the lou
rouevo center for brain health
we're looking for really motivated women
neuropsychologist dr jessica caldwell
has spent years working to unlock the
secrets of why women are more prone to
the cognitive disorder there are things
like women living longer than men
so age is the number one risk factor for
alzheimer's disease and women live
longer
but caldwell knows that age is just one
piece of this complicated gender puzzle
at this point there's good evidence that
other things are contributing
like menopause differences in lifestyle
like being less active than men
and maybe even having more brain related
effects of some
other diseases like cardiovascular
conditions so this new
prevention approach addresses all mental
and physical areas of a woman's life
a thorough evaluation including
cognitive testing
and visits with clinical specialists is
used to chart a customized road map for
healthier daily living
we aren't just you know trying to give
women a simple recommendation we're
giving a
comprehensive plan for women to change
their lives
and one year is where that starts
women of all ages from 18 to 88 from 33
different states have applied to this
one-of-a-kind prevention center and
without a cure for alzheimer's
being able to delay it later in life or
avoid it completely
would be a victory for now just having
somebody
who really knows me and knows
my body and is following it and my you
know and my brain
throughout the course is very reassuring
well the center has funding for three
years and hopes to see nearly 400 women
during that time
in part two we'll talk about some
surprising risks
women have for developing alzheimer's
and the need for reaching out to women
of color
for this center to be successful very
interesting conversations that i had
with dr caldwell and
to find that uh so many more women do
get alzheimer's
and just some of the things uh the
reasons that we're more prone to it
i think women will be surprised and if
you think back or
you know think of your neighbors your
co-workers uh people
that are dealing with it maybe they're
caregivers right now to someone in their
family
and if you think about it you'll
probably think that oh yeah
it was their mother their grandmother my
grandmother my mother
um and oftentimes it's more women than
men
interesting yeah it's uh so finding out
new things
every single day and it's so important
to keep that research going yeah
that lou rouevo center is just amazing
sherry they do
uh remarkable things over there and they
really encourage people to get involved
in the clinical trials and the studies
because if we don't keep doing that
we're not going to keep finding
uh the answers yeah and how amazing if
we were able to really prevent it
mm-hmm that would be incredible so it's
the first time we've ever even thought
about preventing it all together
delaying it would be great preventing it
and then finding a cure would be the
ultimate
we look forward to part two tomorrow